why would i want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else but not like that
deranged khloe kardashian kept news of
baby number two completely under wraps
and now we're learning more about why
she held the secret so close
tristan and i are
i don't even know if i want to say
tristan and i
i am having another baby the 38 year old
reality star and her ex tristan thompson
welcomed their second child a baby boy
via surrogate back in august
after it was revealed in december that
the nba star fathered a child with
another woman while he was still with
chloe naturally cameras were rolling as
it all went down
what is in the media is sort of things
that we feel we need to film because
it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long and during the season two premiere
of hulu's the kardashians chloe reveals
that just days before the scandal broke
the two did an embryo transfer to their
surrogate in hopes of having a second
child together we did
an embryo transfer
like days before thanksgiving and
i found out about tristan's situation
the first week of december
coco claims that tristan knew he was
having a baby with this other woman all
the while he was also pushing her to
move forward with the surrogacy process
i was definitely very angry and i think
feeling
bamboozled
all i know is i was being courage to do
it by a certain date in hindsight he
always knew when the other baby was
being born and he found out july 2nd so
he did know
and chloe admits she worries about what
people will think about the timeline
it's just so close i wouldn't want
anyone to think i did this after the
fact
why would i want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else because i'm not that much
of a sociopath
i'm a lunatic but not like that deranged
and keeping this news private was coco's
top priority i have to make sure it's
fort knox it's crazy i want to
keep this private for like my loved ones
as long as possible
i can't hear about this for months about
what an idiot i am
like what a dumb i am
all these things from everybody else
like that's the part that's like
i think the anxiety like i can't even
begin to think about that
of course chloe and tristan who share a
four-year-old daughter true split
following the news of his latest
infidelity but she still allowed the
basketball pro to be at the hospital to
meet his newborn son
i've been on the fence about having
tristan come to the hospital or not it
looks like true
i don't think that's a cheater
but this tristan wants to be here so i
just figured why not
let him come i'll never get this moment
back
a source recently told e.t chloe is
doing well and trying to gauge the
dynamic of her relationship with tristan
but that will come in time right now her
focus is her baby
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style it's hard work for all parties
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
[Music]
you